I
So I'm five minutes late for my own divorce. I'm rushing from the parking structure
to the courthouse. And all I keep hearing in my head is, "I know you're gonna be late, Horace.
I know you gonna be late, you're always late." That's my wife.
"I know you goin to be late." I'm like ooh! I'm not gonna be late. But unfortunately I don't
have any time travel capabilities. So I rushed through security
security. I get on the elevator. I go past four other floors, I get to mine, I jump off and
off, and...
No one's there.  I look to my left, there are a couple benches.
three doors. No one. I look to my right. Some more benches. Three more doors,
more doors, no one.
See there. I'm worried about being late. She's not even here. Matter fact no one
is here. There were tons of people in the lobby and people on the other floors. But I'm the
first one here.
Have time... I sit down. I adjust my tie, fix my shirt.
Now I can go over my head what I want to say to the judge.
Because it's only going to be me,
my wife, and the judge. Neither of us have attorneys. And I don't want this divorce.
This is her idea.
Now granted I have given her a reason to want a
divorce. But that's not the point. [laughter] I mean my parents
have been married, at this point,
for thirty-six years. They have a great marriage. I know a marriage can work. I mean I'm-a tell the
justice. I'm-a tell him, "Hey! Just give us some counseling. I love her, she loves me, we can
work this out.
So I've gone over this a few times in my head. And I'm noticing time is going by.
At this point it's almost thirty minutes, and I'm getting bothered. Like, wait a minute. Did the court tell me to get here early?
So they can just wait all day? And finally a door opens. I'm like, yeah, finally.
And I see my wife walk through the door.
Well at least she was before she came through the door.
comin from?
It's over Horace. What do you mean "It's over?" Look
"Look at you! I knew you wouldn't be here! Look at you! You didn't even make it to our divorce!"
"What you mean divorce? What do you mean it's all over?""IT'S OVER!" I'm like, "No, it can't be over! I've been sitting out here
for twenty minutes!"
And my wife is so smart.
I mean I'm smart too. But she has an uncanny knack of asking me questions that I somehow forgot
to ask myself.
Why didn't I come inside? I don't have
a good answer. I was just....It's over
"It's over." She hands me the papers. And that's when it hits me.
I just lost my wife.
I mean I just lost... my wife.
My marriage is over.
And I literally sat
there and did nothing.
Now and this might not seem like a big deal to you because people get married and divorced every day.
Sometimes they even do it in the same day. [laughter] But for you to understand the
magnitude of this divorce you gotta understand my wife and me. I mean I still
remember the exact second when I first met her.
I'm a comedian. I got booked as a new comic at this brand new comedy club.
At the same time my wife had just gotten hired -- she wasn't my wife at the time --
as the new bartender. Now I had just gotten out of a bad relationship two years ago.
And
my friends told me, "Man, you have to see this new bartender at the comedy club." And I'm like, "Look, later for that.
I'm trying to focus on my career, focus on my two daughters. Camay who's seven. Kamaria who's three.
And focus on my relationship
with God. That's enough.
Plus, I don't even drink. Never have. What I look like being with a bartender?
So I come in the club I walk down the hallway. I've bend that corner round the left and I see LaFawn behind the bar.
She is amazing!!  So I'm walking towards her
walking towards her I'm like: come on, think of something to say, you are a comedian. Think of something funny, make her laugh. They like that.
So I walk up I'm like.
"'Scuse me. Can I get a Coke on the
rocks?" She
laughs. I'm like yeah, I got her.
And she is amazing. I mean she has this beautiful long hair. She has these black stirrup
pants on with these black boots that are seamless -- you can't tell where the boots end and where the pants begin.
She's like some cute little
superhero. So I'm talking to her and it's my turn to get on stage. But I'm about to up
there and really kill it now. And not because I need to get paid and not because I want to be funny. It's because I
got impress this new girl I just met. So I'm up there and I think the best thing to do is talk about
her. I was like yeah, I asked
the bartender for something to drink. She gave me this little bitty cup. I said, "I wanted Coke
not Nyquil." Oh the crowd
is loving it and I look over and see her laughing too. I'm like, yeah. Reelin' her in.
All I'm thinking at this point is when I get off stage this can't be the end of this night. I got to talk to her after this.
So I get to the bar and I see her going to peer through the
curtains. I'm like, "What's wrong? Is there a problem?" She's like, "My ride is
not here. Supposed to be here."
Here's my opportunity. "Hey you need a ride, I'll be glad to take you home." What I didn't realize until
later was that she called her ride when I was on stage and said, "Hey girl. I'm good. I don't need a
ride." See, I told you she was smart. So we get in
the car, we're ridin' home. She tells me that she has a daughter. ?Noelle?, who's almost two.
I'm like I've got two girls, ?Camae? and ?Kamari?. Look at it we had a whole full back seat
already. Now it's time to talk about the most important things.
"Hey. What's your favorite movie." She's like, "You know what movie I loved, I saw.
I love it I can't stop quoting it." I'm like, "What?" "Austin Powers Two, The Spy Who Shagged Me."
Who Shagged Me"
I'm like, "What! That's my favorite movie too!"
THIS HAVE TO BE GOD, he put us together. Matter fact we're talking
about it so much we like, we got to see it.
But it's not at the movie theaters now. So I'm like "Hey, let's go rent it. Let's go to Blockbuster." So
we stop by her sister's first to pick up a V.C.R. That's how long ago this was.
I mean Blockbuster is still open.
open.  [audience laughs] So we go
So we go in there. I don't have a membership. But I do happen to have all the money from my last three
last three work weeks on the road workin'.
So I discreetly, but nonchalantly, pull out this big knot of money.
the pay for that movie?"
She's like, 'Oo, he's a baller.' So I buy the movie, we go back to her house, we watched
the movie, it's watching us. We start kissin' like we're in high school. Man.
It's amazing. We spend the night together. And that morning I leave. It's like
I leave. It's like, she'll never be out of my life. From that
day forward we've been in each other's lives. Now fast forward a couple years of dating.
I ask her to marry me. We're so excited we're planning for December wedding.
But we get kinda anxious. Neither one of us wants to wait. So we go to a justice of the peace down
in Ohio. Get married by a judge on the courthouse steps.
So now we're married. But now instead of a December wedding, we're planning a
December birth. Our first child together. Another girl. Trinity.
She's born on Christmas,
Which is my birthday. Come on how cool is this. So the next year I have
the biggest opportunity in my career, I'm on television. I'm traveling. Things are going better. And
within a year, we have another daughter.
?Mica?, five girls. And my wife is an amazing mother. Know what?
My dad actually says that my wife is the best mother in the world. Now I don't know
how he says this when my mom is sittin' right next to him.
But
I get his point. She is truly amazing. She makes all of their birthdays a unique
event. Other people even trying to hire her to plan their kids' birthdays. Then a year later we have
another baby. ?Halan?. Now we get six girls. We need two back seats now
now. We're going along, we're being good parents. But we're not
sharing like we used to. I'm spending more time on my career, that's why I'm successful. She's spending more time
on the kids, that's where she's successful. But now we're not quoting movie lines to each other. Now we're starting
to quote arguments in things we said wrong to each other
other. Then we have our first son who comes prematurely.
Xavier, he's only two pounds. This is a real traumatic time for us. A lot to go through.
And somehow it doesn't push us closer. It pushes us further
apart. but that's so far. Because a year later we have another child.
Isaiah. And he's born on Xavier's birthday. Another
cool thing. But this coolness is not enough to keep us
together. So we end up back where the story started, at a divorce.
Now. I'm going to be a good dad. I am. She's a good mom. So we're going to be in each other's lives.
I'm not going to go too far.
Matter of fact even though we're divorced we end up having another child, a couple of years
later. Little ?Astin?. (laugh)
So now I'm dating other people, she's startin' to date. But I'm still missing
my wife.
And I tell her even, "You know what, we're going to end up back together." And she likes to say, "No, Horace,
I'm a marry somebody new." So then one day, it's the day before Mother's
Day. And I said, "You know what, I know you plan on going to watch that big boxing
fight tonight" (cause we both are big boxing fans). I was like, "Instead of that, why don't you come hang with me? Let's hang together."
She's like, "No, I got plans." I'm like, "Come on, let's hang together and talk." She's adamant she's
not coming. So she goes on her merry way. Now I could have went out to watch the fight myself.
Could have hung out with my boys. Or went and found a girl to hang with. But I decided to go back to her house.
I went up to her room and had a talk with the Lord. I prayed. Pulled out
my Bible. I was honest
I was honest with myself which
which I wasn't always doing, because I always knew there was something more
in me, but I didn't know what I was waiting
on. I think I was waiting on that moment.
I told God what I was willing to do what I wasn't willing.
I asked him for what I really wanted. I said "God, if it's supposed to be that, then let it
happen." She came home that morning.
Now I know fights don't last all night, so I know she just wasn't at a fight party.
But that wasn't the most important thing. I sat her down and said, "Look, we can fix this.
We can fix our relationship and be together and have an amazing
life. And you need to tell me and be committed. And if you can't do that, then I need to leave.
And not just this house. I'm leaving the state. I'm moving, I'm a pursue my career. I'll
take care of the kids. But there's no way I can stay here in this city and watch you be with
someone else when I know you the woman I love."
You know what she said? She believed
me. She said, "Horace, you said something like that before,
But I really believe you now.
And I think it's because I believe myself."
We were in love on Mother's
Day. About two weeks later I asked her to marry me again. She said yes.
And this is how I really knew things were going well. One morning she was takin' the kids to school.
And when she went at the back door the door almost fell off the hinges. Now normally this would have been
an occurrence where she hollered at me, "Horace, you need to fix this door, what's wrong with it?" But instead,
she said, "Hey baby, be careful coming out the door, 'cause it's off the hinges." And normally I might have still been
sleepin' because I'm like, "I pick the kids up in the afternoon, you take 'em in the
morning." But I was up and dressed. Now before she could get our kids to school and come back with her morning coffee,
morning coffee, I have been to Home Depot. I good wood, nails, screws,
hammers, saws. When she came in the house, I
was putting on a new door. She gently stepped past me: "Excuse me."
I saw her going to the dining room to get on her phone. She 's like, "Girl, you ain't gonna believe
this. Yeah I know, 'member I told you the door was broke?
He is building me a new door. Not just the door, the frame and everything! Girl, he
got a hand saw!"
I was like, yeah, I got her again!
So we did more that summer than we did in the last five years. We traveled everywhere.
I worked with her at her job. She created her own face painting company. I'm a comedian, I'm painting' faces
faces. But I'm in love. She's coming to my shows with me. It's amazing. We decided to
plan this wedding in November. But again we can't wait. So she's like, Hey I know. Let's
do Nine Ten Eleven.
I like the date. But all the venues are booked up." She's like, "Man." So jokingly I tell her
in front of my brothers and sisters. "Hey why don't you go all the way -- nine, ten, eleven twelve."
She's smart, she's like "Yeah, that'll work." Like, "What do you mean?" She's like, "Because the venues are
available on nine-nine-eleven.
So she gets a beautiful place. We rent it. We decide to have our
have our reception first. So from eight o'clock to eleven fifty nine we have a
great reception. And then at the stroke of midnight. Our pastor marries us on Nine Ten
11/12.
Twelve.  (soft laughter)
It was amazing. And I remember the week before the wedding she came to me real quietly and
said, "Baby, I gotta ask you something. I know you love me,
And you know we got nine children.
How much of this getting back together is about us
us and how much is about the kids?"
I said, "Look,
forget them kids.
[laughter]
Because if we do this right one day going to grow up. They going to find spouses of their own and get marrieed and start their own
families. It'll still be you and I. This is about you and me."
And I think to something my dad likes to say. Him and my mama been married for fifty years.
He always told me, "Horace, Me and your mom are related to you. But we're
not related to each other
The only thing that keeps us together is that we CHOOSE to love one another.
And the Bible says, 'He who finds a wife finds a good thing.'"
I found my wife. Then I lost her,
but I found her again.
And I'll never lose her, again.
[Applause]